the former British intelligence officer
Philip Ingram joins me now I suppose
we've got claim and counter claim the
fog of War do we really know what has
happened in fact I suppose one thing is
certain it has pretty much been
flattened and obliterated oh completely
flattened you know it's day 452 of
Vladimir Putin's 10-day special military
operation and we're talking about back
motor yet again the first shells landed
in bakmut on the 17th of May last year
and it's been heavy fighting to try and
capture it
um from the the Wagner private military
group
um headed by pregosian
um for at least the last nine months if
not slightly longer it's a tiny little
area on what's a 1200 kilometer plus
front line that's equivalent of from
here in London where we are to Barcelona
and we're focusing very much on back
mode and that's a significant piece I
think
what about any kind of successes for the
ukrainians I suppose they're holding the
Russians there so that's fairly positive
what else it is a success well if we
look into black mutants and see what's
happening um you know a few days ago the
map this Orange area was where Russia
had confirmed to have captured up to
they claimed the purple hatched area and
then only a few days later this morning
the assessment has changed slightly
different the Russians are claiming a
little bit more now speaking to a friend
of mine on the on the ground only this
morning he says they're still fighting
in the western areas in um Ukrainian
Hill trenches and in amongst some of the
buildings
um but you're right in mentioning you
the Russians have been advancing in
ukrainians have been fixing them in
place and they've got their defenses
down
um now outside back mutton and those
very early edges and been letting the
Russians slowly but surely Advance
through because that's allowing to trade
a little bit of space to buy time and
that times allowed the ukrainians to
um attack and a trit a large number of
the Russians that are coming in
estimates of over 30 000 Russian dead in
recent months
um and
um to allow the ukrainians then to take
large numbers of their troops off send
them off to the west to get trained in
Western tanks Western infantry fighting
Vehicles Western artillery um and get
them refreshed ready to come back in for
potential counter-offensives
um pregosian has already turned around
and said that uh his Wagner private
military group have had success this is
him
um uh earlier today just in front of
um the the railway building and we have
duplicated this particular video
um in into backwood he's held this his
troops have held this for you're quite
some weeks now so you know he wasn't
right at the very edge of the front line
but I wouldn't expect him to be brave
enough to go and do that now that fixing
you talking about that's quite
encouraging isn't it for the ukrainians
as in what might be lying ahead it is
and it's fixed the Russians in two ways
it's fixed them um physically in bakmut
and there's been reports over the last
few days of the Russians moving troops
from other parts of their occupied
territories into reinforce what's going
on back mode and Prague said he's going
to move his troops out at the end of
this week so troops need Russian troops
need to move in to do that and it's
fixed psychologically as well as we're
all focused on that the ukrainians are
preparing for the counter-offensives and
I think there's three areas that that
could happen the first one is back in
the back mode again as pregosian pulls
out and the Russian regular military
move in that's always a difficult period
for the military and could be exploited
by the ukrainians if they wanted to
um and another option that is in the
Northeast like they did with hurricane
earlier they take a big bite of
territory back again they did that quite
successfully last year in harkiv and the
Harrison and the final option I think is
from zapparasia and if they're feeling
really Brave down towards the sea
there's a few areas there where you can
cut the lines of communications that are
essential to that land bridge from
Crimea therefore isolating Crimea
further and isolating the troops that
there are in the donbass region that
Russia's been fighting for